[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
la journée de l'entrepreneuriat étudiant
est un événement majeur pour l'ensemble
des établissements du sud francilien
pour à la fois présenter des projets
portés par des étudiants mais également
pour faire en sorte que les étudiants
qui ne sont pas ou qui n'ont pas d'idées
ou qui ne sont pas encore entrepreneurs
puissent ou souhaitent le devenir
oui envie de le devenir nous rassemblons
ici environ 70 projets qui participent à
la fois un concours de pitch mais
également un salon c'est une occasion
pour ces étudiants de tester leurs idées
de les présenter un écosystème
professionnels de faire en sorte
d'accélérer le développement de ses
projets et pourquoi pas un jour faire en
sorte que ces projets aboutissent à une
un service ou un produit concret qui
inondent le marché
l'idée c'est vraiment de regrouper la
communauté d'exposer les projets de
faire des contacts avec des entreprises
et des investisseurs mais également de
sensibiliser
les futurs étudiants entrepreneurs donc
la nouveauté c'est on a amené en fait
150 étudiants issus des universités
d'evry et puis panthéon pour être au
contact de ces projets est menée sur
tout un programme learning by doing donc
apprendre en faisant être vraiment au
contact des pitchs commencé à comprendre
les postures des entrepreneurs noté et
discuter avec des professeurs sur place
des projets donc c'est vraiment un
programme super actif parce qu'on est
très consciente la sensibilisation au
coeur de la sensibilisation il ya tous
les enjeux des entrepreneurs de demain
donc si on forme les étudiants
entrepreneurs aujourd'hui ensuite on a
des entrepreneurs qui s'empare des
projets et qui créent leur entreprise
trois quatre ans plus tard et qui
rentrent en tant que étudiants
entrepreneurs et qui suivent également
notre diplôme étudiants entrepreneurs de
paris saclay pour nous la journée
entrepreneuriat étudiant
c'est un événement incontournable sur le
territoire je pense que c'est un lieu
de veille économique concurrentiel qui
est très pertinent pour des entreprises
en fait ce sont des entrepreneurs
aguerris qui vont donner leur vision à
des jeunes entrepreneurs
et ça il n'y a jamais rien de cloche
j'incite toutes les entreprises à
participer à ce type d'événement 1 parce
que j'ai persuadé que le lien entre ces
jeunes entreprises naissantes et les
anciennes créeront demain de la valeur
pour le développement économique et pour
l'emploi du territoire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]